[Music]
alright guys we're leaving Japan I
pretty much lost my voice I'm Korean I
know Tokyo literally nothing we're gonna
learn though a whip in Korea
okay I can't strain my voice
[Applause]
we've landed in Korea
[Music]
not to popping me anyway we're in Korea
I don't think I'm gonna be talking very
much your voice pursued KC's gonna have
to take over most of this trips lon
just another hotel room
another night meant oh really
oh nice let's get comfy here
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna be looking at for the next
seven mornings your voice mm-hmm
these do you remember that one drink
last time when I lost my voice when I
drink the drink the miracle drink you
think to work within it tumeric kombucha
yeah it's kind of cute
you're not making fun of giving if she's
happy and we get to experience Korea
true yeah yeah is that a goal of ours
post marriage is a or post wedding is to
spend Arden our post wedding two
different meanings there sorry last year
her Paris a year before that we were in
their second year wedding anniversary
and the year before that do we travel no
you're at home those oh yeah yeah
where's the wedding we've been traveling
everywhere anniversary
oh dear I'm good again cool we could spy
on each other movie poop and shower
you're like oh this is a not the kind of
moment to be a part of yeah how was neon
sent for you the spa Japanese spas it's
disgusting really you didn't like it oh
really
no I liked wait they're like four times
you kept going
you kept going back to it I liked it but
I didn't like the part that you could
have winter shorts
you mean the naked part yeah who's this
for the bathroom no there's a closet mmm
I like Asian solutions because Japanese
cool they call these people they're
really really smart with their spaces I
guess Korean they're forced to because
of the small living spaces
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first day in Seoul and wearing this very
luxurious the whole bunch of other
youtubers so we got invited out so this
whole thing is called like subscribe
doesn't feel that lonely when you're
vlogging but yeah we just have breakfast
and now we're sitting on to our first
adventure any of that you know of course
you didn't he never does we're first
going to some place called K style hub
which I have no idea what it is I tried
googling it last night but I still don't
understand what it was so we're gonna
find out huh
what are you guessing I think I had
something to do a session because it
says style on the name a lounge like a
Korean history tourism experience Korean
cuisine culture center Korean culinary
culture exhibit hey the Korean culture
okay so we just got an entire tour of K
style hub and what it is so pretty much
it's by a Korean Tourism so they have
this really cool place where you could
come and get all the information you
ever need about the entire country of
Korea they have all these really cool
interactive exhibit where you can even
put on like a VR headset and like see
the scenery
and take some photos they have some
really cute little little stations for
you to take photos and they also have a
medical tourism section where you can
get information about certain types of
surgeries that you want to get you're in
Korea and like though don't point you to
the correct hospitals and the good
doctors for you to get it with I don't
know this is really interesting it's
usually a tourist touristic offices that
I've visited they're kind of boring is
just a lot of pamphlets I mean there's a
lot of pamphlets here but they even the
way they organize it's really creative
and really nice though I don't I really
enjoy this like you can really tell that
they put a lot of care and a lot of
consideration a lot of thought into
organizing this entire place or tourists
so they don't feel so lost and like
confused and like you know it was really
fun - what do you see baby you see
mountain if there's like be breathing
nature beautiful national charities are
they speaking Korean yeah so you could
take photos of k-pop stars and all these
things why you can take a photo with I I
want to do that
one wait what am i doing stand inside
the line
[Music]
hey that's cool look at that
like how fun is it I've never seen this
in 26 Torres on the board office is that
real height I think there's a short I
don't think so i'm 5-4 so here's the
medical tourism office i was talking
about be like right up there to medical
tourism and then they even had this
thing right take a stress level test and
then skin analysis and then you can
figure out your BMI your body
composition so it's pretty cool because
we picked the number three kpop fashion
and beauty for this event the subscribe'
Korea event so that's definitely
something I'm looking forward to is
getting to know all about k-beauty
and we're also gonna be learning about
kpop
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so now we're doing a Korean
cooking class this is cool we clearly
get to actually good bread cause we want
to play on the floor sorry to get up
here we're gonna learn how to cook
Korean food I didn't see how about that
all right we got our stations we're
gonna be making some J and oh yeah it
totally butchered that I'm not learning
to say it properly in a little in a
minute I'm just waiting it just doing
the cooking class right now everyone is
crowding her with cameras I think it
looks kind of funny
okay no Casey added another camera
[Music]
you feel productive nice we're doing a
great job dude because you and I are
working on one soondubu and daddy has
his own I think ours is gonna taste
better than daddy's waiting definitely
it's like without it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we finished eating then I
can't pronounce I should have learned
food you get no and then the other one
oh yeah okay yeah if you like the food
that we meet that was awesome I pretty
much let him do most of the cooking this
feels very eager there's really cool cuz
the chef came over and she was like keep
it really like he could really cook they
keep very calm he's not nervous
all right so now we are at the Korean
National Museum so we're really gonna
learn all about Korea and its history
look there's a robot that's cool too
using the robot to help us be guided
through the museum English hello nice to
meet you I am a guy so we're gonna be
creating and carving out our own stamp
that's pretty cool
so apparently it's a very traditional
yet still very modern way of using your
signature so people create their own
stamps and then that's pretty much their
signature and so we're gonna get to
create our own and I'm kind of nervous
because I'm not very artistic Lee
inclined so I'm not gonna be able to I'm
just gonna wing it
that's gonna be an ugly stamp but
whatever we're making our family's it'll
the family sigil join the ranks of the
Starks and a Lannisters he's finally
finished seasons of it again with around
I haven't seen the last two episodes
I've been avoiding social media because
I'm very scared of coming across and
rear spoilers but by the time this
videos out for sure we would have seen
it already
so yeah I brought them to the dark side
so we're gonna be using these
instruments here to create our stamping
away sharp
[Music]
you like your name in Korean it's kind
of cool I never realized Korean was a
was a phonetic language as she's still
able to retain a lot of green in college
that's dope she's like I'm just so
nerve-wracking I know right you don't
know myself so permanent
oh yeah so I was helped with these two
characters and then I did these two so I
don't know we'll see how it comes out
once I start carving Ojai zzyx carving
hey good job baby all day it's actually
pretty easy
[Music]
angers you're carving a multitasker I'm
a woman she fixed Isaac's to be nice and
clean and she's carving out the edges
this is my final product I hopefully she
can fix man all right I finished looks
like kindergarten all over again
test it out you can send a raven now
send a raven to John Snow
[Music]
look at my schedule
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]